good morning believe nation today's
message is start with the perfect
experience over to you Brian Chesky TV
and Paul grams said something to me that
I'll never forget he's now written an
essay about he said do things that don't
scale and it's counterintuitive and what
that meant for us was we were able to go
door to door meeting every one of our
users trying to provide an amazing
experience and if we had only relegate
ourselves to a bedroom or our office
apartment you know because that's the
only thing that seems scale but we would
never created an amazing experience and
oftentimes the best methodology is to
start with the perfect experience with
just one person get that right and then
figure out how to scale something great
instead of scales I mean not so great
and then try and improve it that's
really hard to do when I make videos in
this youtube channel I don't sit down
and think what's going to be a hot video
what video is going to make me a lot of
money or drive me a lot of traffic most
of the videos that I make on this
channel start with me and I try to
create a perfect experience for myself
this end special series i started for me
because i wanted to have motivation and
excitement every single morning not just
at three o'clock in afternoon when i
happen to watch some video or happen
read a book or have to have a
conversation i wanted to bake it in to
my regular morning and experience to
have something that excites me motivates
me so I designed the interested series
as a perfect experience for me what do I
want to see every morning I designed the
top 10 series and the mentor me series
to try to introduce myself to new big
thinkers and new entrepreneurs we're
doing amazing things and spend a little
bit more time with them and hopefully by
being around them a little bit more some
of the way that they think some of them
some of their beliefs some of their
actions have to rub off on me a little
by little the more I spend time watching
them listening to them hanging there
that the mower that's gonna rub off on
me I think me a better version of myself
i started the belief life series because
i wanted something beyond just business
i wanted something on the weekends to
help me think about my life as a whole
you know one of the things to think
about relationship and stress and all
the things that we talked about in the
bleep license it started with me like i
wanted it for me for my life I wanted to
create the perfect experience for myself
I wasn't happy with what was out there
and so I designed it for me and I share
it with you guys and thankfully you like
it and appreciate it so when you're
thinking about your next product or
service think about creating the perfect
experience for someone whether it's
yourself because you are your own
customer or your customer there who is
not yourself think about how can I make
the best possible solution just for them
and if you hit that right then the
growth will take care of itself so the
questions a today is what are you doing
to improve the experience or your
customer leave it down in the comments
below I'm curious to find out excited to
see what you guys are up to and i will
join in the conversation thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events vessel
nespresso TV go